he's awesome hello I'm coming to you
today from Los Angeles I went to the
Griffith Observatory today and
everything was so green and verdant I
decided instead of doing video game WTF
let's do some real life WTF I pulled
together some of the grossest facts I
could find in this book 1001 facts that
will scare the [ __ ] out of you and I
loved a bunch of my l8 that you make her
friends with the facts and you try to
make them puke let's see if it worked
alright Todd thank you very much for
recording this one's really important
did you know that while you walk around
during the day like that just don't move
alright here's the deal
during the day while you walk around and
move your body's own weight compresses
your joints ligaments and tendons so
that by the time you go to bed at night
you are 8 millimeters shorter than you
are when you wake up in the morning
fresh and expanded it makes me wonder if
you're in space without the gravity to
compress you back down how tall would
you grow to be would you just continue
to grow yeah I think you just keep
growing Neil Armstrong actually by the
time I got back from moon was 20 feet
tall and that's a fact
Vsauce doesn't lie so I'm looking at
these crazy cutaneous horns I don't know
if you've heard about rush see humans
humans can actually grow a horn that
looks like a devil horn in the topic
what's it made out of it's made out of
like your fingernail it's really away
yeah they don't know what causes it but
they guess that maybe exposure to
radiation that's why I guess the only
thing doctors have really concluded is
that they make me horny
I'm the director so just say what you're
gonna say Tom thank you for filming
goodbye please I'll be the director
today okay then here I'll do my
impression of you oh you're gonna throw
a tantrum maybe saw some of these images
at Chinese food guess what they're not
images at all it's a map of seafood
restaurants Oh a cat fighting a warrior
crazy subscribe guys let's stop joking
around and talk about the u.s. in the
year 2000 obstetrician Alan zarkan in
New York City performed a c-section on a
woman when she was giving birth and he
thought he did such a good job but he
actually carved his initials AZ into her
belly I mean I thought everybody did
that I mean oh when I was circumcised
I've been initials from circumsized oh
oh well I know that was like a time you
can pay extra for that if you want
what's up L what's up michael michael
from vsauce here to tell you that if you
wear a ring there can be more germs
underneath it than the population of
Europe that is disgusting
that's why I'm not wearing a ring today
but you know what I was wearing mark
speedos from yesterday's Key of Awesome
shoot
yikes those things are made out of razor
blades damnit sorry Michael did you know
that our stomach acids can dissolve a
razor blade in less than a week I did
not know that you want to try one let's
try one all right check back with us in
10 days up can I get some salt Oh hmm
I'm here with star from the wing girls
she gives out great dating advice and
star did you know that in your lifetime
your salivary glands will produce enough
spit to fill two Olympic sized swimming
pools wow I did not know that that is
who spit you know I created this whole
sexy to tie that's why the pool is so
warm and so slippery okay Wow I mean I
can think of so many times where I've
been kissing a guy and the one thing I
think it's like man if there's only more
saliva right now I'd be so happy this is
Andre for black nerd comedy and I am
forcing him to stare into the Sun
because this fact is a doozy there are
six point seven billion people in the
world and mathematicians have calculated
it based on that at any given second
there are 4000 people doing it right now
and here's another fact it will never be
me if the four thousand people that is
so sad you deserve some shade at there
ah so there you go those are a bunch of
gross facts but let me know in the
comments below what is the grossest
thing you have ever seen for me my
roommate back in college boiled up a
bunch of octopi and sort of forgot it on
the stove for weeks and I had to then
clean out a rotten fungus filled
tentacle pot it was great but let me
know below if you can top that what's
the grossest thing you've ever seen and
hey as always thanks for watching